you know i said that i wanted to sort of
summon the vanderbilts and the
barrymores uh to this conversation
i i think on my side they're probably
drinking somewhere so i don't know that
oh well then they're probably in good
company i am from a long line of
alcoholics okay um
and hedonists and creatives and
brilliant people that i love and i feel
their blood running through my veins i
feel
a responsibility for it but when i was a
kid you know i grew up with a single mom
in a very
uh economically challenged environment
and
i i always felt a little shy about i i
wanted to talk about what it was like to
really grow up
in a single mom
economically challenged
way and i felt like i didn't have the
liberty because people just assumed that
my life was different because of my last
name which is it's so interesting
because uh my mom was gloria vanderbilt
and i grew up very happy that my last
name was not vanderbilt and because i
think if you have a last name that is a
big name like barrymore especially in
the industry you were in that you were
put into as a child
you walk into a door and there's
assumptions that are automatically made
in your case and you said and i saw that
very early on in you know in my own life
because
when i was a kid people didn't know who
my mom was i was a cooper and nobody
cared and you know people treated me
normally and then when they would find
out who my mom was there was always kind
of a subtle shift sometimes not so
subtle sometimes subtle i worked as a
waiter uh
in when i was like in high school and i
remember i worked at this restaurant
that i was underage so i got a job
because my mom knew the guy who owned
the place and i used to eat lunch there
with her
and when i would when i was there as a
waiter i was serving people who i had
eaten lunch with with my mom
but they didn't recognize me when i was
their waiter because they didn't even
look at the waiter and it was it was the
greatest education to see
okay when i'm sitting at the table with
her this is they see me in one way
they don't even see me when i'm not
there with her and and they don't think
they have to pay attention to me and so
to me that was a
such a big obvious wake up and and clear
sign that you know no for me the idea
very early on was implanted that no good
could come from
you know being associated with the
vanderbilts the history of the
vanderbilt was very fraught for my mom
to me they were like ghosts from a past
i really didn't want to know about um
and i chose to have
my story be my dad's story which was
growing up poor on a former mississippi
and i thought as a young kid i looked at
my mom's side of the family my dad's
side and i thought you know what i'm
going with the mississippi side because
that is
i want that to be my american story more
than the history of the vanderbilts when
you see your documentary when you're
here to talk about this book the amount
of chapters in your and your mother's
and her family's life is
it's that of movies and novels it
doesn't seem real there are just layers
and layers and layers it's like an
american crown on netflix i mean it's
it's just nuts how many characters there
are and
um dramas and people who are larger than
life and uh you know it's this
incredible story of this guy who in the
late 1800s made the largest fortune the
world had ever seen at the time more
than like the treasury yeah he had more
money than the u.s treasury at the time
he had one out of every twenty dollars
in circulation belonged to him um so and
when that is a family member that's
gonna color
the way people yeah
he had a pathological interest in making
money and he made a misfortune and you
know that infected the pre the next
generation the subsequent generations
and i think it affected a lot of them in
a negative way and that they didn't
really work they didn't have to work
they just pursued their interests and
pleasures and votes and stuff like that
um
and by the time you know i was grown i
was a teenager and uh you know that
money was all gone and and i was very
you know my parents informed me very
early on that there's not some pot of
gold waiting for you there's no trust
yeah you know you're gonna get your
college paid for it and then you'll make
your own way and i thought that was the
way it should be but
um i was very happy to know as a little
kid
i i would have to make my own way and
and i think it it certainly i don't
think i would have been able to work as
hard as i have if i didn't think that do
you remember was there a spark was there
something that happened in your life
that
was the catapult
you know i think anytime i i think for
anybody you know here watching who lost
a parent early on or lost and
experienced loss early on it that for me
was a huge turning point my dad died
when i was 10. my brother died by
suicide when i was 21 he was 23. um and
that you know seeing
uh it changed the trajectory of my life
and it changed the way i viewed the
world and it changed what i was
interested in and what i was concerned
about and you know like you i wanted to
work from i wanted to work from a very
young age to earn my own money and to
you know prepare a future for myself and
um
yeah which is why having a child for me
has been such an incredible thing it's
something i never really dreamed i'd be
able to do did you
question whether you'd be a parent i did
yeah i mean i i because my mom and i
were very similar my mom had this
relentless drive to she had a lot of
traumatic experiences as a child uh and
she
developed this this kind of relentless
ability to push forward in spite of you
know my brother died in front of her um
you know she experienced a lot of
traumatic things as a child being taken
away by the courts from her own mother
um
and that relent that that drive is an
amazing thing in terms of trying to
achieve stuff but it also doesn't make
necessarily for stability or
a stable kind of home life and i was
worried about
what kind of a parent i would be would i
you know would i be more like my dad
would i be more like my mom and you know
it
took me a long time that's why i had a
child very late in life because i
thought i don't want to repeat the same
you know patterns that i grew up with
it's a real privilege also um i found if
you get to
there's no wrong way to do it if you do
it early you get to have more life on
the other side if you do it a little
later in life you have a lot more wisdom
and patience but it's just so win-win
yeah i mean i certainly i think i
definitely you know i did not want to
have a child when i was still kind of
trying to figure out myself and and now
i feel like you know i'm 54 like if i
don't know myself now it's a little you
know and damn you look good
god have you ever not been
hot sure
to pick up a copy of vanderbilt the rise
and fall of an american dynasty and i
can't recommend moore one of my favorite
documentaries i've ever seen in my life
nothing left unsaid anderson cooper
you literally are my nightly night it is
such an honor to do this
[Applause]
[Music]
you